hey how's it going bro this money's pip
ha welcome to Indies vs. gamers if you
remember we did one I don't know how
long ago it doesn't matter it's
basically a game jam hosted by me
markiplier and jacksepticeye a bunch of
awesome developers made games for us or
everyone to play and compete against
each other that theme is arcade so I'm
gonna play the five winners then you
bros can check out the game afterwards
see if you can beat my high score first
game is ecco by y word holy crap this is
awesome
whoo yeah I'm so cute I can't believe
they made this game in just a couple
hours damn that's that's hardcore
alright so I can upgrade my [ __ ] but I
don't have any coins alright let's try
and go upwards
yeah ow I guess I'll keep going up yes
all right that doesn't count
that is not cam to my high score okay I
said procedurally region generated -
that's cool
love the music [ __ ] awesome
my god why do I suck so bad I have to
beat mark and Jack come on oh my god is
getting intense not sure how I feel
about this how am I gonna go up here
okay I got approached don't worry MLG
pro pip I here to save the day how in
the heavens
how in the hell when I could shoot no
one told me I could ah
this changes everything oh my god so
that's how you get coins okay oh [ __ ]
there's a timer - can everyone just
chill best gamer gamer in the universe
go go go I don't have a lot of ten come
on
yeah boy oh no no I ran out of time
fifty thousand I got a fifty thousand it
said clearly fifty thousand amazing so
that was echo really cool game really
impressed by it changed my life
next game is pinata bash by slot slot
machine
yeah oh can you feel it
Wow all right here we go pinata bash Joe
oh Jesus crisis is intense
[ __ ] yo pinata [ __ ] I'm wreck you when
I can break everything oh my god
Jesus Christ yes best game ever not to
push oh my god I'm so sorry I have a
problem it's not me it's you
get away bald man drew troll oh my god
it's so creepy stop doing that okay
dubstep mode [ __ ] yes
no you're so cute I feel so bad not the
bald one second they're all dead to me
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on guys yeah no so close love that
game
[ __ ] awesome pinata bash alright next
game is Supernanny sleep time Ultra HD
Alpha Omega if this is not the best game
it at least has the best name yeah
alright alright alright wow what is this
C or J okay X yeah I got it when piled
up bashed okay this seems awesome one
yes sleep go to sleep ah ah there my
face get off my [ __ ] face go to sleep
go to sleep go to sleep
ah
punch these kids to sleep let me live my
life I feel like there's something wrong
about beating up kids at the same time
it feels right you know Oh break it down
this is pretty much how I would babysit
I never had any younger nephews ready
big I don't know what I'm doing I think
I'm just about a meshing but it's
working and goddamn it go to [ __ ] the
sleep
Jesus hi sleepyhead wow so many flying
babies how many babies do these parents
have Jesus Christ come on gotta get a
new high score brush I am the one this
is so intense
oh my god Oh sleepy time so many babies
how do they almost fit okay am i killing
them I'm killing them our time no shed
men how do they get what did I get like
I'm sure I got a yes I love that game
that was [ __ ] awesome very cool I'm
very flattered how much effort and
talent went in she this game jam so far
very cool and we still had the last two
to go
sushi Dubai dip too man Mukherjee um if
he didn't win the jam he had leaves won
our hearts with his weird-ass name I
guess okay this looks [ __ ] awesome
all right side of his work left and
right space to begin okay cool it
reminds me a little bit about at that
fishing game
I got its name no sushi I make a sushi
ha ha oh [ __ ] that's awesome wait are
omitting Chris so I collect my fish
let's get that one no I can't all right
come on I need more fish that's a big
one yeah Oh Sean wait are omitting
Christmas ha ha ha
if I can love this game oh so much in
the deep oh my god music [ __ ] yes wait
oh my god so awesome wait our remit
decrease how did I lose a life I don't
know all right let's keep skip going I
guess
[ __ ] love the music this is Christ
oh okay after okay
don't jump over these okay so that's how
you lose um I am one even in the name of
[ __ ] and then a pony
alright [ __ ] it
a rainbow pony Susi sure why not
dominate a love this game so cool
sorry Tony alright ready
oh no I got too many fishies last game
oh man this has been so so cool so far
this is the winning it title it's called
racketboy okay here we go
ee - ooh Indies vs. gamers nice Jesus
Christ racket the boy I'm inserting the
coin okay this looks cool oh my god this
music is sweet euphoria kill the Ducks
or whatever the [ __ ] they are
I think I'm just swiping the Raynaud's
to be honest as I shoot back with a shoe
that makes
oh cool
yes oh my god so many balls I love balls
so it's kind of like pong almost and him
[ __ ] awesome way
this is so addicting I forgot that I'm
supposed to talk over it just like
trying to play it oh my god it gets
really harder oh my god I love this game
so cool
I'm so focused I don't know if you can
tell
Oh tender - the good tennis elbow come
on come on ah no dammit all of the
brofist there ah amazing okay so what
happened so that was all the winners
thank you so much to everyone who
participated we got like 700 games or
something that's so cool I love these I
think it was amazing uh so so talented
people uh making games I don't I don't
know what else to say but it's it's
really really really cool thank you both
so much for watching remember to check
out these games and all the others I'll
leave a link to it in the description
there are so many more that aren't gonna
make it to top 5 but are still like
really cool to check out and that's all
for me for now thank you both so much
for watching see you next one stegal I
don't need I don't know
what's next
ours fill them all right she has he or
she item I don't know
she has arms am